qu'est-ce qu'une tapinose
une tapineuse
alors gendarmes sans on va parler de
votre livre mais comme on dit que vous
appelez aussi Jean Lefebvre
on va faire un test d'identité je serai
plus tranquille quand même votre vrai
nom c'est Jean Lefebvre ou Jean
d'Ormesson
Jean Bruno Vladimir France la Paul
Lefebvre
on va voir si c'est bien vous quand même
votre numéro à l'Académie française
c'est combien
est-ce qu'on dit un ou une pétale de
fleurs
1 bien qu'est-ce qu'une tapinose
une tapineuse
[Applaudissements]
genre
c'est une figure de style exprimant de
manière satirique une idée péjorative
bravo
qu'est-ce qu'une Anacoluthe c'est une
rupture c'est une discontinuité dans la
construction d'une phrase c'est le vrai
gendarmeçon
que fait un nyctalope
et voilà la nuit bravo Jean bravo
alors
qu'est-ce qu'une Mary [ __ ] une marée
[ __ ] je crois que c'est une forme de
bateau bien un bateau à fond plat très
bien
alors là
attention aux amis si je m'y connais en
bateau
qu'est-ce qu'une cuni cultrice ça doit
être quelqu'un qui cultive le
cunnilingus non
c'est quelqu'un qui élève de la page
alors la création du monde c'est Robert
Laffont donc pourquoi cette idée de
donner la parole à Dieu probablement que
tout romancier se prend un peu pour Dieu
et moi j'ai pensé que Dieu était le plus
grand des romanciers et que souvent il y
a des gens qui disent ma vie est un
roman mais c'est pas ça qui est
intéressant ce qui est intéressant c'est
que notre existence à tous l'existence
même du monde existence de l'univers
tout ça me paraît être un roman
extraordinaire ça vous permet en tous
les cas d'échapper à l'autofiction qui
est tellement prisé de nos jours ah oui
ça me permet de faire autre chose que
les autres c'est un livre qui est parti
sur le sentiment de qu'est-ce que je
fais là et quand vous vous dites quand
vous êtes à l'Académie française vous
dites qu'est-ce que je fais là avec tous
ces types habillés en scarabée je fais
ça l'Académie je fais ça aussi ici bien
sûr je me dis mais qu'est-ce que je fais
là et vous vous dites jamais qu'est-ce
que vous faites là si sûrement tout à
coup on se dit mais mon dieu c'est ça la
vie alors les ventes sont excellentes
genre les les critiques aussi plus
personne vous tape dessus quoi
maintenant c'est peut-être triste
alors ça s'appelle la création du monde
c'est chez Robert Laffont et c'est de
gendarmes et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna latitude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu